pas de giacometti et analystes
financiers analystes financiers et
gestionnaires de placements chez claret
bonsoir soir clément milite avec moi
jean paul et clément gignac et vice
président principal économiste en chef à
l'industrielle-alliance qu'on retrouve
par skype
parce que vous revenez depuis quelques
jours de l'étranger clément gignac donc
vous devez appliquer en quelque sorte la
mesure annoncée par le premier ministre
le gourou depuis l'examen ou des raisons
préventives donc j'écoute le premier
ministre ont fait déguster les rails à
part cette maison me joins de vous qu'en
pensez vous de ce qui se passe
présentement clément gignac bien et sait
ce que c'est du jamais vu leur voix
s'entend mais vous savez un jour on va
trouver un vaccin ce virus là donc faut
des gens comprennent que ça va peut-être
en forme de v l'activité économique on
appelle ce contraction récession des
mots importe de plus là c'est que dans
le fond ça va durer un certain temps
peut-être quelques mois peut-être tout
au plus deux trimestres donc mais
quelques rares soyez assurés que les
banques centrales qui ont assuré tout le
monde depuis un certain temps que les
ventes a bien capitalisé qui peut subir
une récession qui a pas de bon qui va
faire fuir dans les prochaines semaines
puis quelqu'un besoin d'un prêt à
présenter l'avant pour avoir un très
long ce qui viennent des provinces qui
était décevant de recevoir d'abord
monsieur de femmes c'est premièrement la
partisanerie en disant que c'est un beau
d europe et tout ça à la réalité on
certains leaders veto dans une situation
de même d'avoir des mesures
constructives
oui on écouta santé publique la santé
publique font les bonnes choses
très peu de personnes en pourcentage
vont mourir de ce virus là mais à la
réalité il faut stimuler l'économie et
nos pour aller dans une forme de
protectionnisme qui fait en sorte que
l'industrie du touriste et tous tous
pour un mort c'est donc oui on fait des
bonnes choses mais il faudra voir des
mesures de support pour que des
compagnies aériennes puissent survivre
et est encore dedans six mois lorsque
les gens ont commencé à voyager de
nouveau jean paul giacometti
vous en pensez quoi qu'est-ce qui est
quel regard vous poser aujourd'hui sur
ce qui se passe ben c'est un moment
historique
on va se souvenir longtemps donc on veut
ça fait longtemps ça c'est pas prêt à
céder correction de cette ampleur j'ai
un peu d'accord c'est une situation
ponctuelle
le mini d'incertitude on ne connaît pas
tout à fait ce qui va se passer on a
beaucoup de pères beaucoup d'émotion
mais ce n'est pas une crise à la 2008 où
le système capitaliste s'effondre c'est
un arrêt une pause et on verra si ça
pose sur beaucoup plus longtemps que ce
qu'on croit ça sera très pénible mais
c'est pas ce concept en même temps et là
je veux présenter un graphique à l'écran
où on voit l'évolution boursière depuis
justement la crise financière marché
aussi gain de 4 100 % mais le marché
baissier parce qu'on est en hausse de
20% de recul une perte de 26 27 pour ça
il se merci marché baissier arrive
rapidement jean paul giacometti fait la
profondeur est quand même importante il
la vélocité et la vitesse de chute est
important oui tout à fait je veux juste
vous dire ce graphique par contre est
linéaire donc la chute paraît plus petit
que ce qu'elle est linéaire voulant dire
que une chute de 1000 points quand on
parle de 30 mai la palme un pack une
chute de 1000 points terreur de 10000
donc la chute est quand même
passablement forte ce qui est surprenant
c'est la vitesse est probablement la
vitesse en rapport avec la complaisance
qui s'étaient installés depuis plusieurs
années donc des gens se retire parce que
les rendent compte qu'ils devaient pas
être autre tableau que je veux présenter
à l'écran depuis la seconde guerre
mondiale tous les marchés baissiers
depuis la seconde guerre mondiale là
vous voyez là depuis 1946 donc b recul
de 20 25 30 40 jusqu'à jusqu'à ce qu'on
a connu en 2007 2008 2009 la chute de 56
57% du s&p 500 à ce moment là on a
l'impression qu'en quelques jours
clément gignac on approche de ses
marchés b s'il a alors que ça prend
généralement plusieurs mois à perdre
autant de points en bourse vient juste
comme sur les tests bord d'une plage et
toutes les faisait beau puis tout d'un
coup on ne nous a rien qui nous arrive
qu'on ait pas prévu donc tout se fait
plus vite yves demain soyez ça vient de
changer aussi faut penser que c'est
comme si on avait comme une crise vers
dole qui va durer un certain temps
la réalité c'est que oui des corrections
ça arrive
plusieurs depuis 1950 une trentaine mais
des verts marquée du marché pc de plus
20% en eux environ 12 m en moyenne ce
sont autour de 30% pas ce qu'on doit
faire une distinction actuellement c'est
peut-être qu'il y avait de l'euphorie
une correction normal mais là ce masque
où le bât blesse c'est l'absence de
coordination des chefs d'état du g20 ou
des ministres des finances du g7 ou du
g20 pour travailler ensemble pour les
banques centrales font leur possible
mais ça va prendre un gouvernement qui
injecte beaucoup au niveau fiscal ou
monétaires budgétaires pour éviter que
les gens perdent leur emploi pour
coiffer taux de chômage passe de 4 % à
15 % dans le manche matin que les
gouvernements viennent avec des mesures
pour que si les gens doivent rester chez
eux pendant un mois tient bien il va
avoir une part et parce que vous devront
payer leur hypothèque mais est-ce que
c'est là le danger
clément gignac une espèce de spirale en
ce moment là on en parle
les événements sont annulés les
autorités publiques surtout fortement
sur la place publique les marchés
chutent lise l'inquiétude grandit est ce
que est ce qu'il n'ya pas une spirale
qui pourrait nous amener quelque chose
qui peut se rapprocher de ce qu'on a
connu en 2008 2009
non moi je ne crois pas parce que
écoutez c'est pas les banques c'est pas
parce qu'il avait fait les banques à
2008 sera complètement différent savez
une bulle immobilière et la des banques
y avait pas un bon bilan
cette fois ci les ventes sont très très
bien capitalisé donc si les compagnies
des chaînes d'hôtels marriott ferment
qui ont besoin d'argent
si c'est pour les banques qui vont de
prêter sa voix que les gouvernements
vont regretter parce que cette économie
doit un jour voir partir vous comprenez
ce que je désire donc dans ce sens là
oui une part mais l'actionnement la peur
se propage plus vite que conrad virus
selon gerald donc à quelques pas mardi
matin qui a une concertation dans les
prochaines heures et prochains jours
pour éviter que cette pandémie mondiale
deviennent une grosse récession mondiale
avait des conséquences sociales serait
beaucoup plus grave et à long terme que
la pandémie qui sont insérés man 2 mo
ins conservant récession là où effectuer
sa voiture une récession l'homme mais
une récession c'est une transaction
d'économies pendant quelques mois
ce n'est pas une dépression et moins
jeunes voient pas le chômage passé de 5
à 15% l'eau mais il ya des mesures
préventives qu'on fait et les
gouvernements
ont compensé soit les entreprises soient
les individus opaque on met des gens en
difficulté pour ces communes acte de
dieu continent l'est moins de
connaissances mais par contre pourquoi
que les marchés ont réagi aussi mal
aujourd'hui c'est pas parce que le
nombre de cas peut nourrir de
s'augmenter c'est l'absence de
concertation de la part de monsieur tron
avec son blues des réformes
et ça les choses vont changer vais
travailler dans cadre du g20 avec
monsieur clarté à l'époque
et quand la crise devenir 2008 2009
c'est quand le g20 s'il ramène une des
finances et travailler ensemble on doit
pas travailler seulement la santé
publique font la bonne chose une
concertation mondiale 60 bull et ça
promet de concertation mondiale des
leaders et chefs d'état et ministres des
finances jean paul giacometti vous nous
avez apporté un tableau très intéressant
sur l'iran demain après les crises
sanitaires
au fil du temps par exemple le sida
l'éclosion c'est en juin 81
un mois plus tard on perd de 0.54 douze
mois plus tard on perdait 14 5% le
strass cependant il y avait un rebond
alors qu'est ce qu'est ce que ça nous
dit ça que l'évolution boursière à la
suite de ces différentes pandémie ou
épidémie donc il est tout d'abord juste
une petite statistique c'est que le
marché boursier en moyenne baisse de 11%
au cours d'une année
d'une année à l'autre ça c'est des
éléments déclencheurs et des épidémies
pandémie donc ça déclenche une baisse
parce que des fois c'est associé comment
81 avec d'autres circonstances
ce que ça nous dit c'est qu'une fois que
la base et effectués comme en ce moment
2 25% si vous pensez vendre c'est pas
une bonne idée
c'est pas que ça va baisser davantage
ses statistiques mans on d'ici un an ou
deux vous retrouverez votre niveau
actuel
même si le marché continue à baisser un
peu donc c'est des éléments ponctuels
c'est pas des éléments qui touche la
structure de l'économie au complet seul
arrêt temporaire
espérons le c'est le seul point qui est
un peu différent tous ses colosses c'est
cette fois ci aux concertations à
ralentir l'épidémie au maximum donc
espérons qu'elle nous faisions pas six
mois ou 9 mois plus tôt que nos trois
mois habituels de
vous êtes quoi la région ce soir si vous
avez pas vendus et que vous voulez
vendre c'est parce que vous n'êtes pas
prêts à attendre d'eux parce que 2008
après 25 cents ans après seulement deux
ans pour récupérer cette baisse malgré
la chute qui a suivi après donc on parle
pas de retourner au niveau où on était
donc si vous avez pendant de vue et vous
vendez êtes probablement vous devriez
pas être dans le marché boursier est
aussi que ceux qui vendent aujourd'hui
statistiquement ou par expérience pour
écrire vous n'arriverez pas à m'acheter
où vous allez juste voir le train pape
clément gignac est encore tout à fait
d'accord avec les conseils 5e de mon ami
jean paul écouter quand on est allé
boursiers pas pour changer surtout dans
six mois ou acheter un condo dans un an
c'est parce qu'on est là le long terme
maintenant j'ai quand même 8 milliards
d'actifs sous gestion aujourd'hui on a
acheté plusieurs dizaines de millions de
dollars de banques américaines européens
qui sont à 40 45 % de baisse mais qu'un
rendement du temps de 4 6%
je sais pas moins d'une semaine dans
deux semaines si ça soit 15 % plus bas
mais je pense que dans six mois pendant
un an puis dans 2ans n'ayant suivi
conseils de jean paul et l'expérience
historique que je serai pas fâché de ses
achats et nos clients vont être assez
contente d'avoir gardé